douze sur douze pour la majorité
présidentielle dans les yvelines tous
les candidats étiquetés ensemble pour
ces élections législatives se sont
qualifiés pour le second tour certains
sont largement en tête les députés
sortants jean noël barrot dans la 2e
arrivent premiers tout comme béatrice
piron dans la troisième circonscription
par rapport au résultat je crois que je
suis assez sereine on va dire parce que
je pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de
réserves de voix sur la gauche et que je
ne pense pas quand même que les
républicains où les gens de reconquête
irait voter qu'à même pour malin brody
donc je suis assez sereine les autres
favoris ont répondu présent dans la 5e
circonscription la députée sortante et
nouvelle ministre les outre mériel bronn
privée largement en tête face à la
candidate nuxe dans la 12e
circonscription karl olive vire en tête
ce dimanche 12 juin avec une confortable
avance sur les devine le gris mais
l'actuel maire de poissy vont rester
prudent on mène bien la mi temps et tant
mieux et on va pas on va pas sur
l'excusé mais moi qui suis compétiteur
vous savez que tant que l'arbitré n'a
pas donné le coup de sifflet final
rien n'est gagné il faut rien mais
estimé des candidats devront en revanche
batailler dans plusieurs
circonscriptions dans la septième nadia
et arrive en tête avec 29 points 55% des
suffrages 2 points de plus que son
adversaire tout se jouera ce dimanche
dans la 8e edwige hervieux devoir
refaire son retard même tendance dans la
11e aurait lié à pia senza aura fort à
faire face à williams martinez candidats
nous ce n'est au second tour face à lui
c'est maintenant notre principal
objectif c'est que toutes les personnes
qui une fois de plus son républicains
sur un projet qui est diamétralement
opposée face à celui qui est proposé par
lannux on appelle à la isation de tous
ces électeurs en 2017 la république en
marche avait raflé onze circonscriptions
sur 12 pourront-ils faire aussi bien
cinq ans plus tard réponse ce dimanche
19 juin pour connaître le résultat des
urnes